okay I've got a dead cow again nope this
cow thinks it's still alive I'll take
care of that excuse me Cal I would like
to take you to the lake please cooperate
by being dead oh I won't you just die
hey Sean hey Danny how are you doing I'm
doing well how are you I'm doing great
i'm surely looking forward to playing
grand theft auto online but
unfortunately these servers are
currently down for maintenance so our
boat is gonna be Michael in our own
little universe here yeah it's great GTA
online features a robust offline
component the GTA 5 really yeah oh we
should play some of that damn you should
I'm gonna take a book out of the nerd
cubed youtube channel which is a very
popular grand theft auto 5 youtube
channel and do a what's called a yoga
ball challenge you see this yoga ball I
do big blue see it's right behind you
there yeah I'm pretty much focused on
this cigarette really I wouldn't like to
I couldn't smoke with this mask on it
would just melt my face off and but yeah
they said this uses the the physics
which are currently sadly not really
available in Grand Theft Auto online but
as you can see this board jumps around
and stuff that's what I thought would be
a good ideas if we try and get this ball
and into the ocean so the first person
who gets this ball into the ocean winds
the video game we win this episode of GG
a diary this has been a competition the
whole time all right yeah I like it so
yeah let's go ok here we go get dive
right into it this is already
exceptionally difficult yep the beach is
not close I think I've already got stuck
oh I'm gonna try and die i think i
figured this out I figured it out it's
not running isn't it the trick is to not
run yeah you have to gently caress it so
how long do you think it's going to take
Emily but lovingly that's already got no
not the kitchen I know mine is going
towards the pool does it pool players
also go towards the pool we've owned by
eyes the desert pool counter the ocean
you know I'm very close to the ocean Oh
water only oh look at this look at this
it's on the kitchen outside Danny I'll
see you later I'm about to go to the
ocean a great part about being outside
is well I can push it with my gun hahaha
that's a great that's a bad idea hey
like if you want to do that No did you
destroys out you can't push it with your
gun oh well uh i'm using the power of
gravity to move my i gotta see if i can
move with the car actually what have I
done respawn damn you
I'm gonna move a little maybe if I take
a quick nap I'm gonna save the game okay
my god punctured my eye pokes your mind
my stupid car yeah it's out onto the
street you're on the stage i'm just
gonna let gravity do its trick you
better hope gravity doesn't require you
to push it up a hill after you've gone
all down all those hills yeah you're
right cycling in San Francisco if it's
taught me anything it's the great
downhill piece of [ __ ] I don't know what
a car drove into it hahahaha loaded I
fact that this challenge may be
virtually impossible Yoga Yoga Yoga few
thousand your yoga balls gonna get
destroyed in about five seconds oh yeah
but it goes into the road yeah okay I
got to protect it with my job cars I got
to protect with my body are there any
vehicles where you can get away from my
book ballin swear to god swear to god
they need to see without again you oh
Jesus Christ where's my ball gone get
away on his way too much traffic I might
have messed up I might have messed up go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
how do i open the convertible on it
convertible lb or something or hold out
that's the button I press to shoot my
door is it your whole left or something
or hold left the left d pad for like a
couple of seconds or some [ __ ]
you can do it you can do it no no no oh
you think you're good woman still oh
you're gonna die oh you're gonna die you
were gonna die oh I don't believe you do
you know how long do you know how long I
walk down the street with that ball you
stupid dog you were gonna explode you're
gonna explode my wife is drunk on the
couch you need to repent for what you
have done to my balls ball ah there you
go I feel a little bit better about us
come on yoga ball cannot believe that
happens I cannot believe the haven't I
think my wife is angry at me because I'm
stealing her yoga ball ah this is the
worst all right I have a better idea
okay I have a better idea this yoga
[ __ ] is doing my head in uh I have a
better idea there's also there's loads
of objects are in this game that aren't
in GTA online proper okay including
animals so I have a better idea how
about we try and get a cow all right
where am I gonna find one of those so
how about you try and get a cab into the
water anywhere just thought of a goal is
to get a cow into water get a cow into
water all right I just don't know where
to find a cow is the problem I'll show
you where to find a cab okay I'm map the
direction you pointed me towards yes is
a prison wait you didn't go to is there
a prisoner there's a prison there you
said that's the place where you can go
and get a cow I don't know what kind of
presence lang kau is but I do not want
to get a cow or if quote unquote put a
cow in the water your first night inside
you got to put a cat in the water okay
i'm sure you have a pretty cow there boy
how else are you gonna form alliances in
prison if you're not putting account
with water we sure do got a pretty
cowboy yep oh i found the perfect
vehicle for Cairo transportation please
take me no no no don't know sir my
knee-jerk I need your vehicle so i can
bring a couch of the water if you know
what I'm saying no these guys really
like their JCB all right oh whoa
look at this what you got there
beautiful do you mind if I gently walk
behind you so long that you wind up at
the ocean well I just need to figure out
how to guide it to the ocean I got this
little bulldozer thing look at this all
right how you wait here I'm gonna find a
bulldozer where are you I'm at the weed
farm show me on the map that that's
privileged information today he's and
I'm afraid that I'm in no position to
offer you such things it's not a cow
over there Oh pro tip if you want to
kick start your cow a little bit just
kick it in the butt it's not a cow over
there it's a sort of cow I gave it Danny
what look what's on the horizon the
ocean it's that big old lake okay I'm
I'm gonna try and win this good luck all
right cow on a technicality get run over
there are some speeding cops get in like
you know no get in my bucket tag Ted if
I bucket cam kidding me get in my bucket
cab Oh Cal you run away from the water
right now oh Jesus you did not do that
oh my god this cow is going to be the
death of me you are so close it's above
the water it is on a bridge above the
water I got this deer cow it's like you
guys call these cows in America right no
no I'm not gonna let you play the
foreigner card Danny get in my bucket Oh
Cal no don't you run over my cow you
piece of [ __ ] oh no no look how close it
was look how close it was Danny its
smell the ocean it could smell the ocean
come on cow you are so close why won't
your body move to the ocean Oh Oh No
this car is stuck on top of the cow oh
look I got this deer in the bucket look
at it it's in the bucket how check it
out I want a fine mood room I think that
forklift will do just fine hahaha you
better hope your cat isn't this a beer
oh I can't believe my cow got run over
by a goddamn station wagon this car this
truck is so shitty that I'm getting out
performed by a dude in a try
turn it's gonna be much harder for you
to carry it on a forklift than it is oh
my god yeah you like this oh my god oh
my god this awful machine actually
performs better on the dirt than it does
on concrete this is way better than the
forklift section of Shenmue for the sake
of feeling partial victory i'm going to
submerge this dead deer into the lake
okay so it does not mean that i win but
I feel like I'll sleep better tonight if
I at least get rid of this tier into a
lever house so close at the end of the
day I still managed to get some type of
fauna into a lake school go into the
lake there you go bye apparently dead
deer don't float okay I've got a dead
cow again nope this cow thinks it's
still alive I'll take care of that
excuse me cow I would like to take you
to the lake please cooperate by being
dead oh I won't you just die this is
going to happen I am so close to getting
a cow into this and you know then it's
only a matter of minutes oh yeah i mean
if nothing else you did get a deer oh
hello cows which one of you wants to go
to the beach alright this came up here
is gonna get murdered hard hey Daisy
what's got four legs and a bullet in
this brain you baby how close are you Oh
got the cow in the bucket it puts the
cow in the bucket I'm impressed I like
how we've used such different techniques
oh oh my god Danny did no no no you're
gonna drop it we're gonna join it you're
gonna just emails now you're gonna drop
it you're gonna drop this you're gonna
drop us oh wow that's close hello heavy
book on completely different ways yet we
managed to end up at the water with cows
within seconds of each other it's
[ __ ] come on hurry up come on little
cow hurry up I'm so close I'm so close
Oh
behind [ __ ] thing oh you got damn cow
you are like four feet away from this is
the final oh now I fell into the ravine
na ho haha just as well Danny just as
well this cow has fight wait for it this
cow this is so good literally way oh
look at this cow Danny yeah I don't know
about you but i'm pretty sure that cow
is sopping wet oh I'm wedged in this
ravine like completely stuck oh look at
this thing oh this thing oh that is a
real wet dead cow look at it in the
sunset in the background that's the most
majestic dead cow you'll ever see in
your whole life I'm gonna get it even
more covered in water Oh No I've driven
the forklift so far into the water that
I can't move it anymore but that's fine
because that cow you see this cow any
completely submerged you got full
submerge on it uh-huh well I'm stuck in
this I'm stuck in this just booked it
with with Daisy here we'll never know
what it's like to be buried see can't
give this this care of Viking funerals
I'm just gonna have to give it a
military funeral and throw a grenade
into this JCB there you go cal Godspeed
you